hey everyone this is feeding master
Costa Kavinsky here for Ches calm and
today I'm going to be doing part two the
video series how to evaluate chest
positions so today's format is going to
be a little bit different instead of
asking you just to flat-out evaluate our
position I'm going to ask what should
white play here blacks last move was
obviously d5 attacking White's Queen and
now I want you guys to think over your
options here and try to find the best
move for white evaluating all possible
moves of the Queen okay so if you need
more time you probably do need more than
three seconds to evaluate a couple of
different options here I strongly
suggest you pause the video and keep
thinking but otherwise we're just going
to move on and talk about this
interesting position okay so the
critical decision that needs to be made
here is whether you want to move the
Queen over to the king side or retreat
it to the Queen side and this is not an
obvious decision to make because well in
order to make the right decision here
you're going to need some accurate
foresight okay well let's start with
analyzing this move Queen g4 moving the
Queen over to the king side but not
offering a queen shade with Queen h4
which would be a separate story right so
the Queen is on the Kings side and I
don't think this is such a good move in
fact I think it's a fairly serious
mistake because there isn't a whole lot
white can actually do on the King side
and all the action in this position is
actually going to be taking place on the
Queen side here so the first thing you
guys probably notice is that black is
down upon in this position right it's
not so easy to see how they're going to
win the pawn back but let's say black
plays this move c4 this is this kind of
an odd position but I think that black
actually has very good compensation for
the Pawnee urn might even be better
and the reason is that White's queen is
actually stranded out on the kingside as
strange as that seems you know usually
you want your queen very close to the
enemy king - sometimes threatened
checkmates and different things like
that
but here white only has a queen and a
knight on the Kings side and there's
nothing that they can really do I mean
okay they can play Knight g5 in Queen h4
and then after black plays h6 then what
right so there's nothing there are no
threats then white can actually create
which means that these pieces actually
aren't really contributing to the game
that much right because this pawn chain
is very solid it's just blocking these
two pieces out of the game meanwhile
black just wants to attack this B pawn
and build a pressure over on the Queen
side here this is going to be very easy
because black can very quickly bring all
of their pieces to the Queen side and
start attacking these pawns here even
though black is down upon here actually
prefer their position for example Bishop
d2 trying to get this poor Bishop out
black and simply play Knight f6
important move because now believe all I
wanted to do here was that if black
takes and the knight takes now the Queen
can retreat to the side of the board
right so nine of six is a very strong
move because it forces the Queen to h4
in the game why it took on a five black
took Queen h4 and now this Queen is
pretty much stranded on the King side
for good and there's nothing y can
really do about it so this actually
occurred in one of my games I was
playing black here I played Queen takes
b5 and I think at this point my opponent
realized that he was actually in serious
trouble here because my queen is fairly
active on the Queen side and I basically
just want to bring my Rex to the B and C
files maybe play Queen b3 c3 open up
this position win both of these pawns
create a passed pawn push it down the
board and win the game and the reason
this plan is so strong is because
White's queen is not you know on c2
defending all
squares the flight screen was on c2 I
think black would be slightly better
because he can use the open file but it
wouldn't be such a huge advantage as it
is here so the game continued Knight g5
I played h6 just to be safe
Knight goes back and what's funny is
that this Knight is totally dominating
the Queen here the Queen can't come to
h5 or to g4 to try to make its way back
to the Queen side because the knight is
controlling both of these squares so
white is basically stuck here and he has
to try to create some kind of
speculative attack on the King side that
really won't work as we'll soon see
so I played rook b8 f3 and here I found
a good move c3 and the point is that if
white takes then I would gladly give up
my Queen for two rooks because even
after these exchanges White's queen is
still stranded on the Kings side has no
way to protect any of these loose pawns
and after something like rook c8 for
instance black is simply going to take
this pawn take this pawn you run there a
pawn down the board or double the rooks
on the second rank and start taking
these Kings side pawns and you know why
it is basically lost a basic way to
evaluate positions with Queen versus two
rooks is to see which side can actually
create threats and attack the enemy King
if for instance you know blacks King was
exposed here or there was some kind of
pawn weakness on the Kings side then
White's Queen will be pretty good
because it can team up with a nine and
attack that weakness but here there's
just nothing to attack on the King side
and black strokes are obviously getting
active very quickly so that's a you know
thirty-second should be on how to
evaluate positions with two rooks
against the Queen basically you want to
see which side can actually create
threats with their material imbalance so
white here played b4 now Queen a4 going
after this weakness and okay I think we
can stop here basically
like has a huge advantage they're not
down upon this pawn is very strong and
effectively we're playing with an extra
Queen here on this Queen side you know
why try to create a tack here with stuff
like g4 and g5 but there just isn't
enough steam in this attack and that's
part of evaluating the position is that
you really have to try to figure out you
know whether your pieces are actually
going to be effective where you place
them and in this case you know running
the Jeep on exposes White's King it
doesn't really do a whole lot for the
attack and blacks epon turned out to be
a much much stronger resource anyways so
going back to this critical position I
hope you guys sort of understood the key
point here is that even though you know
white was up upon this queen being
stranded on the kingside is a serious
mistake and you know cost white the game
so back in this position if white had
played something like Queen c2 and let's
say Rick see a queen e2 and c4 I think
this was the best white can do and here
white is actually probably slightly
better maybe even close to having a
significant advantage because your white
does have an extra pawn and because the
Queen is on the Queen side now it can
support whites Queen side play you know
I can play Queen c2 and bring his bishop
out at some point maybe play b3 and try
to counter black space advantage you
know Black has this nice pawn on c4 here
cramping White's position on the Queen
side but after but if I can organize
this break b3 then you know black will
slowly have less and less compensation
for the four White's extra pawn this
position black definitely has some
compensation because you know their
pieces are quite active and they can
definitely hold back white but only for
so long I think if white plays
accurately and comes up with a good plan
too
reorganizes pieces here on the queenside
eventually white should be making use of
their extra pollen and the last thing i
want to mention about this position guys
is that let's say why play Queen h4
offering to trade Queens and this is
normally a good strategy you want to
trade pieces when you're up material but
in this case again you know you after
black simple move Queen takes h4 you
know I think black is going to get a
nice advantage here if something like
that if sex probably white can take on
c5 and follow up with b4 and I don't
think this is good for black at all I
mean white gets his Bishop to b2 and
suddenly all the whites pieces are very
active but after the simple Queen takes
h4 night h4 and c4 you know again
White's pieces are quite passive and
black is probably going to win back
their pawn soon you know because this
Knight is stranded on h4 this Bishop
can't immediately get out and if Y play
something like a four I think black can
play a six takes rook takes and black is
just going to double the rooks on the B
file and eventually organize this c3
break or simply play rook before and go
after this a pawn here but basically
it's pretty clear that once black wins
back to pawn I'm still going to have a
lot of pressure on the Queen side and
have a better endgame and we see these
ideas often in the Bangko gambit for
those of you that are familiar
you know black sacrifices upon they get
Queen side play and often when they win
back their pawn they remain with a
better position because all of whites
sort of strategical problems are still
here like lack of peace development and
this pawn weakness on b2 and of course
this could have been seen in the game as
well like if I play queen g4 c4 and a4
after something like a six threatening
to you know isolate the speed pawn and
win it back black and double some heavy
pieces on the B file go after this a
pawn or
place III at some point went back there
pond with a probably a winning position
so I hope this was a useful lesson for
you guys the main point here was to
think about how oftentimes a very
important part in the value NHS
positions is figuring out where your
pieces are going to be at their most
useful and here you know my opponent
play this queen g4 very superficially
just thinking oh the Queen should be
near the enemy King but this is a
completely incorrect assessment because
White's Queen and I just really couldn't
do anything useful to this king side
well black achieved everything they
wanted over on the Queen side here and
again the right move was to play
something like Queen c2 and try to
develop some of their pieces like Bishop
d2 maybe b3 at some point with a pretty
reasonable position thanks a lot for
listening and I'll see you around on
chess calm